okay let's continue as it's been a very
very busy 24 hours donald trump as i
mentioned yesterday had this super low
energy
uh coronavirus press briefing it was
just bad he seemed deflated he took only
a few questions
mostly from friendly reporters and then
after
smearing kamala harris and
mispronouncing her name he just sort of
stocked off the stage in the way
uh really i've only ever seen donald
trump uh do very very strange
sort of dynamics and posture to it and
of course what comes out of his mouth is
is not much better
apparently feeling like he needed a
booster
last night donald trump called into the
sean hannity propaganda program
on fox news to i guess sort of try to
have a better showing than he did
during the press briefing but what's not
been working out super well for trump on
fox news
is that he gets fed the most softball
of softball questions and he still
manages to either
mess it up or say something that
actually uh
acutely worsens the situation for him
and
it's like nobody can make the guy look
good almost nobody
although i'll tell you at the end of
this segment who i do think
uh manages to make trump look less bad
and
trump went on fox news spoke to sean
hannity
last night calling from the white house
up trying to take some of the attention
back from the news cycle of joe biden
selecting kamala harris to be his
running mate and it was really weird and
it was really
bad and once again i have to ask how is
it that these interviews keep happening
again and again and again clearly we
know that the people around donald trump
have no control over him
but also even the friendly interviews go
bad like even sean hannity who's trump's
friend and is not
interested in anything that we would
call journalism when it comes to donald
trump
even he can't get trump a sensible
interview so let's look at some of these
and hope that in a few months
this type of nonsense from the oval
office because that's what this is this
is not
you know some uh as as some like to
pejoratively call them
this is not some basement show with two
viewers
uh interviewing some unknown person
this is fox news interviewing the
president of the united states hopefully
in a few months
this type of nonsense regularly coming
from the oval office emanating from the
oval office
will be relegated to the archives as
this happened and it's now in the past
rather than the day-to-day
first here is donald trump insisting
that this
is going to be a rigged election and
this has worked
later in the program i'm going to tell
you about new polling that confirms
this strategy from trump of saying it's
going to be rigged
it's not going to be fair it has worked
and it could actually lead to chaos
during election day election week maybe
we should be calling it
i'll explain that later but here is
trump himself saying it
it's common sense and an absentee
ballot's okay where you send in for a
ballot
they go through a process and they send
it to you and then you send it
it's fine but these mail-in ballots
where they send millions of them all
over the country
it's a it's going to be a rigged
election
and this country shouldn't allow it the
courts have to step in we're in many
different courts right now
if the courts don't step in the federal
courts you'll never know who won the
election just
so this is now on repeat this is just
that he's saying it
multiple times a day trump pretending
first of all that there's a difference
in practice between
absentee and mail-in voting now every
time this comes up somebody will email
me and they'll say david there is a
difference between absentee and mail in
voting
there's a difference in theory okay
we could have a universal mail-in voting
system that would be different from
absentee voting
this time around when we talk about mail
in voting
what we mean is expanding absentee
voting which trump says is okay so that
everybody can get an absentee ballot in
some states this means sending everybody
a ballot
who's registered not dogs not
undocumented immigrants
in other states it means sending
everybody who's registered an
application for an absentee ballot in
other states it means
you still have to apply but saying i'm
worried about catching coronavirus would
be a valid reason to vote absentee when
traditionally in many
elections you would not have that
freedom you would have to
your reason uh for wanting an absentee
ballot would have to be justified in
another way so again trump pretending
there's a difference
operationally practically there is no
difference between mail-in and absentee
this time around and again trump does
allude to
the various lawsuits that he's filing
that is a real concern
that actually might work to gum
everything up
and um we're going to talk about that
later as well in my segment on the
strategy to steal the election that's
coming up later
we'll continue in our sort of tour of
the horrors of this interview last night
here is donald trump complaining i mean
he's just so
whiny have you ever seen a supposed
alpha
complain and whine as much as donald
trump
saying he was impeached over his
so-called
perfect phone call disgrace they play a
much dirtier game
they'll impeach you over a phone call
that was perfect
nothing like that's ever happened before
they impeached me
over a phone call that was absolutely
perfect
you couldn't have made a better phone
call there was nothing done wrong with
that phone call
and they play a much dirtier game a much
tougher game than the republicans
what do you think it's like being
hannity in these interviews i'm not
saying i
envy the guy and i'm also not saying i
feel bad for the guy i'm just saying
what do you think it's like
you're you're trump's friend hannity is
trump's friend um
hannity gives trump the softest of
softball interviews you can barely you
you can't call it journalism you can
barely call it an interview
and trump still goes off the rails into
these disjointed
aimless tangents does hannity worry that
like
wow i'm not even doing anything that we
would call journalism
and still trump doesn't look good and
then somehow trump gets on to the topic
of ranting about pulitzer prizes and new
york times reporter maggie haberman
it's so weird what trump gets obsessed
with anonymous source is also a topic
take a look
they got it wrong and they got pulitzer
prizes the pulitzer prize is worthless
as far as i'm concerned because
when you have the maggie haberman's
getting a pulitzer prize and she got it
all wrong she doesn't i haven't spoken
to her
forever she's like my biographer like
she knows everything about me she knows
nothing about me
and they talk about they have sources
they don't have sources they're made up
they make them up in their mind they
have no sources i know when
there are sources but if you look at the
times and
i guess the washington post they got
pulled surprises and they were totally
wrong
imagine being so arrogant that you
think you know about any story in
newspaper publishes
whether there are really sources or not
now
for i'm not going to bore you again with
the confusion that trump has had for
years
about what anonymous sources are
remember trump
doesn't seem to understand the
difference between a source that's
anonymous in the sense that a media
outlet doesn't publish their name
versus a source that is anonymous to the
reporter
okay in almost all cases when we talk
about an anonymous source what we mean
is
the reporter knows who the source is but
they are not
publishing the identity of that source
trump in many cases seems to think the
reporters don't know
who it is that they are dealing with
anyway the level of arrogance
and narcissism is really something else
and then here is trump
on the same day that we have the first
woman of color
as a presidential or vice presidential
candidate in the united states
insisting he's done more more good i've
done more is one aspect of it but done
more good
for black people than anyone other of
course other than
abraham lincoln as he likes to say i've
done more
for the black community than any other
president
other than perhaps abraham lincoln now
here's just a final little thing
donald trump still unable
to say the word minneapolis send in the
national guard
and solve the problem like we did in
minneapolis
just every interview i mean you have the
full spectrum
mostly you have a spectrum of jonathan
swann pushing back in the axios
interview last monday night
all the way to on the other side sean
hannity
just letting trump rant and he never
makes sense he never looks good he can
never hold it together no matter what
the setup
no matter how freely and uninterruptedly
he's allowed to just say whatever he
wants
sometimes i actually think the
interviews where trump comes out looking
best and i alluded to this before
we've seen trump on fox news fox and
friends
hannity uh janine pirro we've seen the
gamut
we've seen trump in press briefings
we've seen trump with george
stephanopoulos and with jonathan
it's always a disaster trump comes out
looking the best
where understand the level of
babysitting that has to be done
by by the interviewer trump comes out
the best
on interviews for example with the
christian broadcasting network now i'm
not saying
that when trump is interviewed by cbn he
makes
sense or he explains policy or any of
that
what i am saying is just letting trump
rant
is it's bad for trump he looks bad cbn
goes further
on cbn the interviewers will sometimes
rephrase what donald trump says
to make him look coherent that's the
level of involvement you need from an
interviewer even a friendly interviewer
to make donald trump look good it's not
just don't
challenge him it's don't challenge him
and then rephrase his answers and
respond to them
like he's being insightful or
intelligent or coherent and the place
that does that
is christian broadcasting network
there's probably some other i think that
he did an interview with some guy from
barstool sports i didn't even know the
guy
but that was a couple of weeks ago where
again trump wasn't making any sense
it was a friendly interview but the guy
who interviewed
portnoy i believe his name was dave
portnoy dave portnoy
if i'm remembering correctly would
actually
react and respond as if trump was making
sense and that's the degree of help
trump's neet trump needs
in order to come out of an interview
looking even semi-coherent
it's incredible incredible that that's
where we are today let's take a quick
break remember that you can
follow me on twitch for uh frequent live
streams i will say
at twitch.tv david pakman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a 10 a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman